once I was at a backyard wedding and a
random guy rode by in his bike yelling
don't do it
[Music]
my now husband asked my father for my
hand in marriage before he proposed
my dad flat-out said no my dad talked to
me every week and the two months leading
up to the wedding and said I don't have
to go through with it if I didn't want
to I wouldn't upset anyone we had a
destination wedding and while my parents
arrived to the resort he told me he
would fly me back home if I wanted to
right before walking me down the aisle
he asked if I was sure and again
mentioned flying me home if I didn't
want to go through with it it was at a
rehearsal dinner my aunts mother stood
up and gave a big long speech about how
my uncle wasn't good enough for her
daughter and how my uncle would never
amount to anything
my aunt started crying and my uncle told
his now mother-in-law to sit down and
shut up they were getting married no
matter what she said they had been
married for 20 years now and my uncle
his mother-in-law
hasn't spoken to him since my
grandmother is known for making trouble
she really liked my uncle's former wife
they flew my grandmother out to the
wedding and sat her right at the front
next to the bride's mother the priest
asked if the parents of the bride and
groom approve and blessed the marriage
my grandmother straight-up says no my
late grandfather was a reverend he
married my older cousin and his fiancee
my mother brother and I didn't attend
the wedding
but my late grandma told us that my
older cousin was so drunk that he kept
objecting to his own wedding and my
grandfather kept asking if he meant to
object I went with an ex-boyfriend to
his cousin's wedding everything seemed
fine and normal until they asked if
anyone objected the bride's sister made
a small coughing noise and asked if she
could speak to the two of them privately
turns out the bride had a shopping
addiction which put her forty-five
thousand dollars in debt and she'd been
hiding it from the groom wedding went on
after that but it definitely put a
damper on the celebration I was at a
wedding between one of my really good
friends and her fiance who she had been
with for nearly four years then in the
middle of the ceremony my brother a year
younger than the groom
stands up and yells we can't live in the
sly anymore will and proceeds to run up
to the front of the chapel and kisses
the groom instead of objecting the groom
kissed him back and professed his love
to him and what a mistake he was about
to make my friend just immediately burst
into tears and started screaming about
all the time he had cost her she ran out
of the chapel and I followed her I said
no in my wedding it was a super fast
ceremony at her new house with just the
officiant and a couple of people for
witnesses when he asked if I took my
spouse in marriage or something like
that I honestly don't remember I said no
that was about a beat and then I said
yes I thought it was funny at least
right before the wedding my aunt pulled
me aside for a quick walk about in my
dress and everything to let me know she
thought I was making a huge mistake and
she just couldn't watch it happen
without telling me
I accidentally objected to a wedding it
was my first time taking the train and I
walked into the wrong station it was a
wedding venue I was trying to find my
track I was randomly opening doors I
opened the doors at the perfect time as
they were asking if anyone objects it
was quiet and awkward and loud the bride
read the groom's cheating comments from
his phone account as her vows said he
didn't deserve her and that he needed to
excuse himself from the venue we all
watched him tuck tail and leave stunned
in silence she then addressed his family
stating all of you have been so good and
kind to me over the past four years my
respect and love for you has not changed
please join all of my family and friends
at the reception for a celebration of
truth love and freedom to make the right
decisions even though they hurt only his
brother and two friends didn't go to the
reception everyone else attended and had
a blast when my mom told me that my now
except dad proposed I objected she threw
the ring across my room in a fit yelling
at me I don't want her to be happy
[Music]